[Musique]
prenez la dérision non comment il
s'appelle la jolie fille née à gâteau
proulx voilà moi je mise tout sur la
normale sur siège est à lyon benjamin ou
bien et ben voilà ce que vous propose
tous et je pense que c'est mathieu tu es
fan de sport automobile qui celui-là lé
feu et l'a étendu très frais qui
freinera la connais jamais d'accord
j'avais mauvais relais au final qu'une
fille en trois chapitres hilton barack
obama
voyant là on en a plein poutine voudrais
faire un défi avec tout et travaillez
vous devez faire poutine sur le circuit
poutine et le savait mais comme libre
arbitre
outin sur sa machine ça fait mal voyants
et revoir la finalité non et on y goûte
et orientale
je dirais que c'est pas du tout les
mêmes choses dans la question et non
c'est comme si les normes c'est comme si
tu te demander ça parce que tu dois
faire fabriquer à kout a vu que je
tenais ma petite amie qui s'est passé
serait laisseront pas prévu à faire dit
être d'avis ou un finder tone on accuse
on a compris la réponse on attend à
l'origine en bonne forme et je lâcherai
ces deux mecs qui bossent les sens en
moi n'y arrive pas
il a eu tort car les marchands et nous
les jeunes mais et mais effectivement
j'ai parlé avec le marchand donc entre
les deux balances apparemment qui t'aime
pas
[Musique]